here at 605 we have something else
driving you crazy a viewer email about
Construction slowdowns in the speedway
Bowl
Andrew writes a lot of US Travel where
the 215 ends at I-15 for work around the
Amazon facilities getting to work early
in the morning or getting off in the
afternoon the traffic is horrendous when
are they going to finish and why is
Range Road closed off sometimes to go
home I take I-15 South to lamb go North
to get back on the 215.
Andrew first of all that's a pretty good
alternative you came up with other
drivers heading to the northern Beltway
from the construction area you should
think about doing the same thing south
on the 15 up to lamb in the back to the
215. now to answer your question about
when that project is going to end you
may only need that workaround for a
couple more months the ndot website
i-15north.com says work May wrap up
before the end of the year we've got the
link to that website where you can sign
up for helpful weekly email updates on
our website click traffic then driving
you crazy buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone you can join
the driving you crazy conversation at
traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com